foreign
welcome to the show how you doing
hey guys how you doing we're doing great
how can we help
so I'm 21 years old I'm still a college
student I got about a year left I've
paid off everything so far and I'm
currently debt free
um and I'm on track to be able to pay
off this last year every semester as
things go just cash flow
exactly nice
um I I also am in a relationship
um and have been pretty intense on
saving up living pretty uh frugally for
the last um like year or two
um almost maybe too much and I've
realized you know I I've just been
listening to you guys been talking you
know and I've been all about the
intensity of the first two steps but it
sounds like after that things switch
from intensity to intentionality
and I've you know recently just tried to
pick up a third job to make a little bit
extra cash to do things like take my
girlfriend out for dinner and just do
those type of extra things that I
currently there or previously before
that third job couldn't really put any
money anywhere else
um and I guess I'm just wondering if if
even that is the best move with me being
at baby step three should I just be you
know even with that third job making the
money that I'm making there and throwing
it into a savings account to to get
myself through step three as fast as
possible or I I it's kind of almost a
relational advice that I'm asking
um has your girlfriend brought any of
this up
on as far as me doing taking the third
job or not well as far as going hey we
never go on dates and you never want to
spend a dime and we can't do anything no
she wouldn't say anything like that so
so she's cool with all this she's nicer
than me she's not she's not struggling
like me out to dinner that's what I'm
wondering is she reaping any of the uh
you know what you're selling here well
any of these jobs yeah and Gabe I mean
you guys are you're in school is she a
senior as well
no she's been she's four years older
than me so she's graduated um okay I
think two three years ago okay that's
great that's great all right and I and
just so I have this clear the two jobs
you have that is basically going for you
to live off of intuition correct it
builds and saving up towards that
tuition okay okay and then you're
looking at baby step three how much do
you have saved
currently
um this last bit of after this tuition
this next tuition is paid off about
about a thousand two thousand dollars
okay two thousand yep that's great well
I currently have a thousand is for my
safety net this baby summer months but
you know beyond that I have one or two
okay okay that's great and how much
would a three-month emergency fund be
for you because I mean I feel like
that's all you would need at this stage
of Life uh is more on that three to four
months so how much more of that two
thousand five hundred is what I need to
get to ten thousand five hundred that's
a pretty that's a sizable emergency fund
for you what kind of expenses do you
have
say say it again what kind of expenses
do you have right now while in school
currently I'm I'm paying rent
um and I uh have gas you know you need
to pay a little bit of gas to get to
work
um I have a phone bill uh I have uh an
internet bill and in uh car insurance
okay I mean three grand a month yeah
okay so 910 Grand will get you there
that feels right so how much longer
would it take while working these three
jobs to get there if you're really
focused well if I get through tuition
that's kind of my biggest thing is all
all of that saving money has just been I
know that expenses coming every semester
I want to stay out of debt so I've been
using just everything that I make that
goes into savings it's getting used to
cash flow that tuition
um after that's all done I could
probably get that in a year
okay especially if I held this through
this third job
and so you're not out of the woods yet
as far as intends to intentionality
through baby step three we have to
remain intense and because what we don't
want is I thought it was just one and
two that were intensity yeah you'd carry
that through once you get to baby step
four we can pump the brakes a little bit
in our three jobs sustainable Gabe
doing that and schools a lot and dating
yeah I'm doing 32 hours at my job as uh
as a cook I'm doing about 10 hours as a
part-time work with uh my church okay
and then I'm trying to doordash that's
the third job I've picked up okay that's
great I've been doing that late evenings
um yep and you know what Gabe yeah burnt
out I don't feel like I'm really
fighting anything like that that's great
I think that's awesome because honestly
the time to sacrifice like you're kind
of at the perfect season like I know
everyone's like college enjoy your life
but I mean I mean yeah I was gonna say
like you're you're a senior you know
what you want and you obviously have
goals and this would be the time to be
like oh yeah I'll sacrifice and like do
that because once you once you graduate
and you get a job and you're actually
making an Inca steady income obviously
you're making great money now but uh
there's just something about being able
to be like oh yeah I'm like already
ready to invest save up a down payment
maybe for a house and like you get to
move on to baby steps for and Beyond uh
so that so with the dating thing though
I was I mean I was joking with you
earlier around like but she's nice I'd
want to go out to dinner but I mean like
you guys yeah you can date cheap I mean
it's not like you guys have to go out to
nice places and and she obviously
probably knows your goals and what's
going on and I mean there's a lot of I
mean I mean and this would be true for
married couples right or I mean anyone
dating regardless of if you're in
college or not it's just like how do you
live life while doing baby steps one
through three and you want to be able to
enjoy life to a degree uh to sustain
yourself so I mean we always talk about
you know there's there's always free
stuff going on depending on you know
your city you can look that up
um you guys I mean go on a hike I mean
like there's things that you guys can do
together that doesn't have to be crazy
expensive and instead of going to the
movie there's plenty streaming at home
for the Thousand subscription Services
we have and you can always cook a great
steak dinner at home instead of paying
10 times that at the restaurant and so
and if there's a lot of special occasion
that's my job oh that's so true which
means you're tired of cooking when you
get home or he's the best and he can
cook at home used in its restaurant
quality that's true oh yeah Gabe I would
I would definitely that's okay part of
the reason she's dating you now this is
a business right yeah yeah and you know
Gabe too I'll say this like this isn't
forever because I know this can seem
daunting and exhausting and you're like
oh man this is just it's a lot but this
is this isn't your life forever right
it's just for a season to get an
emergency event and honestly well done
for you not only doing it at your age
but that season of life like it will
just Propel you when you graduate and
whether you continue to date her and may
I don't know if it moves on to marriage
or you go and find a career like just
setting yourself up well now it is it's
great so never regret that you're never
gonna go like man I wish I I partied
more in college that would have been so
great for me you're doing the right
things and so I want to encourage you
that you're being weird in the best ways
possible and everyone listening uh
should be encouraged by that what are
you studying
uh right now I'm trying to just get a
teaching license I'd like to teach um
English at a high school level education
awesome that's great so great and what's
awesome too Gabe is like you know
obviously if we we're talking about
Teachers Pay
um maybe a few episodes ago on my show
and I'm like and that's what's even
amazing is I'm like you can choose to go
into a career field that you know you're
not going to go make half a million
dollars right uh but you're able to make
those choices and those decisions
because you don't have payments that
you're going to have to repay so like
that's another reason doing the work on
the front end is so great because you
get to go do what you love and not be
like oh man it's going to take me you
know eight years to get out of the
student loan debt on a teacher salary
you get to take that teacher salary and
be blessed by it and it's great and
wonderful and you've just set yourself
up really well so that's I mean you're
doing a great job and you can still have
a life and still have a great healthy
relationship with your girlfriend and be
on baby step three this is incredible
and Rachel the data shows that students
who work 15 to 20 hours a week have a
higher GPA than those who don't yep that
makes sense to me you're going how is
that possible well Junior has to be real
disciplined with his calendar with his
time or Gabe to do I mean Gabe's working
40 hours a week yeah that's insane Gabe
and so well done and he's still crushing
it he's going to finish completely debt
free and so it's parents who are going
well my son and daughter they shouldn't
work they're focused on their studies oh
really are you following them around
campus all day they're in class for a
few hours a day there's 24 hours in that
day there's a lot of other stuff that's
right they're at the library sure they
wouldn't darken the doors of that
Library I'll tell you that much but hey
Gabe We are rooting for you man way to
go love seeing young people just crush
it and sacrifice now so they can live
their best life